bist du bei minecraft leben dabei wäre
richtig nice hallo meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren runde hatten sie sich mit frack
cover paar fragen beantworten
ich hab mir jetzt gedacht nachdem ich ja
gestern nicht wieder hochladen habe wo
ich mich einfach mal so ein bisschen
ausgesprochen habe über kommentare und
alles mögliche und den herrn
untereinander und das youtube als
maschinen angesehen werden und so weiter
und so fort
mach ich mal wieder so ein praktiker
video jetzt heute wenn ich schaffe kommt
heute sogar noch ein zweites video weil
heute ist sonntag und ich habe sonst
keine anderen stress und muss zwar noch
ein bisschen lernen arbeit mit einfach
werken ich habe mir wieder bei twitter
rausgesucht dass ihr mir unter dem ich
hab getwittert dass sie mir unter dem
hashtag fragen stellen können so was
richtig unter dem hashtag fragt luca
einfach beitritte anfrage gestellt und
wenn ihr fragen habt könnt ihr da gerne
folgen steht in der beschreibung oder
einfach unter dem hashtag eine frage
schreiben
jedenfalls habe ich mir da zehn fragen
rausgesucht und wir fangen direkt an mit
der erste frage die mir zugesagt wurde
vom awi und zwar fragt er bestellt zu
der vinyl soder jagst über flohmärkte
und scratch du auf platten die du nicht
mehr magst und da ist es einfach so an
alle die es nicht wissen ich
plattenspieler und also nicht hier
sondern zu hause
und wieso habe ich eigentlich immer so
ein problem mit diesem komischen blocken
kann doch nicht sein
was habe ich denn für dickschädel hier
die sollte ich denn das ist doch wieder
so eine kampagne komm ich lass mich mal
einfach wieder direkt töten hier von dem
von dem syker dass ich nicht immer die
ganze halbinsel blöden schädel auf dem
kopf rumlaufen mori
hier kommen schlag mich ja danke
die frage zu beantworten mir wurde auch
vorgeworfen dass ich die fragen
schneller beantworten soll weil ich nun
mal so viel zeit lasse oft jetzt ein
café klecks auf dem tisch das kann doch
nicht sagen nächste dahin gekommen so
gar keinen sinn ich hatte den kaffee
hier stehen hier rechts und dann links
ist ein klecks m ich bestelle mir vinyl
zimmer im internet weil
ist da ganz geile seiten gibt um sich
ein paar schöne des menüs oder teilweise
auch checken vinyl zu bestellen weil auf
flohmärkten finde ich weiß man nie was
damit ist und ich habe schon oft
probleme oder ist ein typ ich hatte halt
auch schon oft probleme das da
schallplatten halt irgendwie risse
hatten oder ein paar stellen halt
einfach übersprungen werden auf einer
schallplatte dass da nicht sogar und mit
dem sketch im scratch eigentlich gar
nicht und wenn schon macht das mit allen
platten weil das nicht preis nicht also
keine ahnung ich mache wenn wir nichts
mache damit allen aber sonst mache ich
das auch extrem selten weit darf nicht
vor gut car ist ein deutscher lieblings
youtuber fragt annika also annika das
ist richtig cool hashtag fragt luca ich
gucke in deutschland extrem wenig
youtuber das heißt ich habe eigentlich
in deutschland kein lieblings youtuber
raus also von dem ich regelmäßig ab laut
sap crm einfach weil ich mega mega
witzig finde und sonst wirklich von von
gar keinem ab und zu mal bullshit tv
displays gar nicht außer bei sarrazin ab
und zu mal bei der sie rein weil es
einfach interessant ist aber sonst halt
echt nahezu gar keine videos in
deutschland so übrigens falls es hier
einige eventuell stören sollte das du
wie sie es hin schicken falls es einige
wendelstein sollte dass ich hier nicht
so ganz professionell spiele
beziehungsweise nicht so mega alter das
ist doch kein normales bücherregal da
oben oder konzentriere mich hierbei
halten wir auf die fragen und nicht auf
das gameplay das heißt ihr könnt ruhig
man einfach mal das video minimieren
oder so wenn ihr euch nur die frage
anschauen wollt weil hier welt denke ich
werde ich keinen einzigen haider finden
hallo der behinderten blog so und fällt
hinter dir also ein richtigen lieblings
youtube in deutschland habe ich nicht
elena fragt gibt es bald neuen fenster
von seinem shop
ja die letzten beiden shirts sind ja
recht simpel gewesen einfach obwohl
viele halt immer mal wieder keine arbeit
mitgemacht ich finde gerade solche
simplen sachen auf so simple sachen zu
kommen die cool sind beansprucht viel
arbeit aber cool is ja mal relativ also
wenn ihr jetzt wenn es euch nicht
gefällt dann ist es ja eure sache wie
läuft eine dreier bat darum die einfach
solche leute suchen wir so der suchtrupp
bonn.de also ich planen da zurzeit eine
shirt compilation mit
weil weder bock drauf haben zu dritt
sonnenschutz zu machen weil mit mit matt
und lud sie kann man halt richtig geil o
maten luhmann so illuminati oder so da
haben wir schon ganz coole ideen aber
das wird sich jedoch herausstellen dass
fertig wird aber das kommt auf jeden
fall noch ein nahezu kompletter fragt
wie fühlst du dich nach dem fact video
wo du deine meinung gesagt habe bist du
erleichtert respekt für das video
hashtags luca ich fühle mich sehr gut
ich bin zwar sehr unzufrieden mit dem
video weil ich einfach ich finde ich
habe so lange gebraucht als auf den
punkt zu bringen und ich habe immer
angst wenn er leute dann das sehen dass
sie dann so direkt abschalten weil die
denkt nach außen aber der empfänger kann
er kommt nicht auf den punkt aber es war
halt ganz wichtig dass ich diese
vorgeschichte erzählen wie ich darauf
gekommen bin kann es sein dass dieser
dreier suchtrupp nur mich ich frage mich
einfach wie sowie keine haider finden
und die verfolgen einfach alle nur
minimal an
ich spiel der einzige grund warum ich
heiden siegl letzter zeit immer fünf
spiele ist weil man hier selten erkannt
weil der seiten amerikanischer server
ist aber also ich bin halt auf der eu ip
aber es ist halt trotzdem so ein
internationaler server anstatt irgendwie
komme hd oder irgendwie so dass wenn ich
runter springen
die lucky games tag wie lange bis zu
wegen seinem stück für dich km am tag so
beschäftigt und wo mit irgendeinem
studium bin ich halt also mein ein
durchschnittlicher tag sieht eigentlich
aus dass ich nicht so lange ich bin also
ich sag mal fünf bis sechs stunden oder
so aber jetzt in zukunft kommt halt noch
spanisch dazu und andere fächer das dann
acht fächer habe und da bin ich dann
teilweise schon wöchentlich ein zwei mal
von 9 bis 20 uhr in der uni also elf
stunden nachbarn was essen sport machen
youtube und sohn dann kriegt man halt
recht wenig schlaf reza fragt würdest du
wenn du einen zuschauer mit einem match
sehen würde dass er dich aber nicht
sieht ihn ansprechen
ja grundsätzlich wenn ich merke dass
dort jemand ist der mich eventuell
kennen könnte also wenn dort jemand ist
zum beispiel an der supermarktkasse
letztens als in bielefeld war war das so
ja ich stehe das an der kasse und zwei
leute vor mir stehen halt so die bahn
weiß nicht 15 oder sohn habe ihn ganz
nett rüber geguckt haben dann auch im
internet nachgeschaut und ob ich das
wirklich bin und so hab ich dann halt
schon so helga meinte hey ihr müsst ihr
nicht so auf geheimnis tun wenn ihr ein
foto machen wollte da so dann können wir
das ruhig machen und die man sehe ja
klar das super und so will wie man sich
sicher ob du das wirklich war es dann so
und deswegen einfach entweder auf mich
zukommen oder wenn wenn auch wenn leute
mich dann die ganze zeit so komisch
angucken von der seite oder so denken
ist er das oder nicht dann gehe ich dann
halt auch meistens hin ausser vor allem
wenn die wenn die ein t shirt von mir an
haben wo irgendwie condor auf die
übrigens nett hier ich habe das heute an
etwas umgefallen weiß nicht warum
jeden tag wenn ich einfach zuhause chile
und lernen oder so will carmen ich finde
das mega wollig und warm und herzlich
aber wenn jemand sehen würde der mann
virgin hat dann will ich den auf jeden
fall ansprechen weil es war auch schon
so dass ich mit einem kumpel unterwegs
war und er meint dass er haye die der
vornamen grad würde ich geredet ich
hingegangen hey ihr kennt mich ja wollen
vielleicht foto machen oder so so und
dann meinten die einfach nur so herr wer
bist du so das war schon peinlich auch
wenn jemand halt so ein shirt anhalt
bekommen braucht steht oder so würde ich
auf jeden fall henry fragen würdest du
mal ins weltall fliegen wollen hashtag
fragt luca oh oh ja ich denke dass
ich auf jeden fall ins weltall fliegen
würde vor allem einfach weil das ich
weiß nicht im weltraum ich stelle mir
das so geil vor du bist einfach da oben
und du hast gar keine sorgen du musst
jetzt nicht dran denken ja ich habe hier
bald eine prüfung oder hey ich ich ich
habe jetzt hier ich muss für die
nächsten vier tagen noch videos
vorproduziert fest ich du hast einfach
so keine keine probleme du bist einfach
so alleine mit ein paar anderen weg und
sie ist einfach so die die welt und so
weiß nicht ich stell mir das mega cool
vor sich wird auf jeden fall ins weltall
fliegen
ob deine familie oder gucken deine
freunde deiner youtube-videos ein paar
kumpels gucken mal rein
an der stelle schöne grüße an markus
wenn freddy ich weiß gerade nicht wer
noch so alles immer rein guckt aber die
schreibe mir da noch so teilweise l
guck mal hier eine von instagram vor
deiner seite will mir folgen und so oder
teilweise auch höhe was war das für ein
schwachsinn wie die hülser das immer
schon ganz witzig aber es ist jetzt
nicht so dass jeder meiner freunde
täglich so austickt ob ich neues video
hochgeladen habe und was ich gesagt habe
und ob eventuell über ihn gelästert habe
oder was weiß ich also es ist jetzt
nicht mein vater hatte in der letzten
zeit nahezu nie videos von mir geschaut
weil er viel unterwegs war immer aber
der hat sich halt zum beispiel dass
charlie hebdo video angeschaut der hat
sich der shop sie hat mir mehr solche
videos also ich fragen beantworte oder
aber der hat jetzt kein youtube account
guckt er halt auch nur so manchmal rein
weil weil sie nicht interessiert sich
halt dafür und das finde ich megawatt
mega süß als wenn er einfach so sagen
würde ja mach dein ding verdienen damit
ein bisschen geld und was da sondern der
interessierte auch ein bisschen für und
dafür bin ich sehr sehr dankbar den
gamer hd hashtag fragt luca möchtest du
dich am 4 februar in minecraft
umbenennen ergeben martin
das ist eine sache von der ich noch gar
nichts mitbekommen habe weil ich habe es
gerade nur gelesen hat die frage auch
nur angenommen weil ich eventuell mal
nachfragen wollte ob jeder vielleicht
ahnung von habt wie das ganze
funktionieren soll und zwar kann man
sich wohl angeblich bald in minecraft
umbenennen wenn man mit seinem nickname
irgendwie unzufrieden ist oder keine
ahnung was ich weiss nicht genau
wieso das ganze auf einmal möglich ist
aber wenn ihr da eventuell was alter er
versteckt sich einfach wieder so ein
baum wie stummfilmen jeder eventuell ein
paar informationen zu haben würde ich
mich auf jeden fall sehr darüber freuen
wenn ihr das mal mir in die kommentare
schreiben würde
also ich denke ich weiß nicht ob ich
mich auf luca umbenannt wurde auf
einfach auf lu ca
wer schon irgendwie ganz cool aber
kontrast das hat auch sein name ist
jetzt mittlerweile so weil sie nicht
dadurch bin ich halt bekannt und so
kommt kann ich hoch springen guckst du
die minecraft weitete also ich weiss ich
schreib mir mal wenn ihr wenn ihr lust
habt dazu vielleicht ein paar infos in
die kommentare aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich das bin dann würde da bin
ich mir der der und ich gibt einfach nur
noch einen haider das richtig stark
letzte frage bist du bei minecraft leben
dabei wäre richtig nice
ja also mit minecraft leben ist es halt
so ich habe am anfang so gedacht okay
aber erstmal so gesehen location neues
projekt von simon und so sieht ganz
interessant aus hat mich so ein bisschen
anwalt leben damals erinnert weil wir
halt damals klaus bergmann und ich hatte
mir kurzzeitig das waldleben projekte
aber haben das dann aufgehört weil wir
einfach nie zu dritt zeit gefunden
hatten
und da hat mich das ein bisschen dran
erinnert so einfach so sorgenlos in
minecraft bauen und das ist halt genau
das was ich mir quasi schon immer so als
projekt gewünscht habt nicht irgendwie
sondern konkurrenzdruck sowie gestellt
die meisten güter her mit dem
megaprojekt oder wer hier in hero hat
das heftigste schwert und die krassesten
wie es diese sachen die man auch die
blumen bekommen hat diese teile womit
man sich rüstung macht hat keine ahnung
aber ich möchte einfach ein projekt
wohnen und bauen kann reden kann fragen
beantworten einfach stream einfach
schäbig ohne ganz viel regeln und so
natürlich so dass vivaro zwischendurch
richtig fresh und so das ist richtig
geil so als abwechslung aber sowas wie
minecraft dem habe ich mir schon immer
gewünscht und deswegen habe ich mir das
info video von simon angeschaut hab sie
mir mal angeschrieben und meinte dann ja
man auf jeden fall einrichten irgendwie
und ich weiß nicht es geht das video hat
am sonntag vielleicht bin ich mittwoch
donnerstag freitag vielleicht diese
woche noch irgendwann schon mit dabei
nur ich bin jetzt halt erstmal nicht ich
habe jetzt nicht direkt so angefragt
sage ich mal und direkt am anfang weil
ich halt zurzeit wirklich noch und ich
möchte jetzt auch noch nicht direkt am
anfang mit drin sein weil ich halt noch
klausuren schreiben bis nächste woche
mittwoch
und deswegen aber ich werde auf jeden
fall da mit bye sein also ich hab ich
habe die zusage nennen kann keine ahnung
über zum vorstellungsgespräch
also simon meinte dass er dabei so eine
weitere führung machen wird mit einer
nächsten gruppe und dann werde ich
danach dann denke ich in minecraft leben
dabei sein und dort dann auch teilweise
fragt luca folgen machen und teilweise
streamen und so und einfach so ein
bisschen schäbig bauen mit euch unter
abgenommen und da sind ja auch teilweise
vielleicht ein paar abonnenten dabei
auf dem server deswegen ist es auch ganz
cool und das würde ich auch sagen was
dann auch schon wieder mit der jetzigen
folge von hashtags luca wenn es euch
gefallen da will ich mich über eine
bewertung freunde es ist nur ein klick
und